نش
[Silence]
الله على محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم صلى
الله على محمد صلى صلى الله عليه وسلم
انما الاسلام قوه ونظام
واوه
واخوه واتباع
للنبوه
واتباع
انه دين محمد صلى الله على محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم صلى الله على محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ما له في الخلق ثاني في مزايا
الحسان ما له في الخلق ثاني في مزايا
الحساني كي نفوز بالجنان
كي نفوز زح بالجنان
نتبع الهادي محمد صلى الله على محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم صلى الله على محمد صلى
الله عليه وسلم وحد الناس جميعا عالما
حلوا بديعا وحد الناس جميعا
الحلو بديعا اشرق الكون ربيعا اشرق الكون
ربيعا من تعاليم
محمد صلى الله على محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله على محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله على محمد صلى صلى الله عليه
وسلم
بارك الله فيكم تكبير